a death row inmate in Texas faces
execution in just two weeks unless a
celebrity backed campaign can persuade
the governor to intervene Rodney Reed
was found guilty in the 1996 rape and
murder of 19 year-old Stacey Stites but
his attorney claims new witness
statements and forensic evidence clear
Reed
Omar Villafranca is at the State Capitol
in Austin Texas Omar this case has
received national and even international
attention good morning you're right and
here at the Capitol Republicans and
Democrats don't see eye to eye on much
but a bipartisan group of lawmakers
agree
Rodney Reid's case needs to be
considered again and along with
celebrities they're asking Texas
governor Greg Abbott to pause the
execution and consider new evidence did
you rape Stacey Stites no did you murder
Stacey Stites
talk-show host dr. Phil conducted a
jailhouse interview with Rodney Reed
that aired last month he is just one of
a number of celebrities including Kim
kardashian-west Seth Green and Rihanna
who tweeted at Texas governor Greg
Abbott to pardoned read or commute his
sentence I believe the people family the
supporters support the truth prosecutors
claimed stacey stites was at home in
1996 with her fiancé Jimmy Finnell a
former police officer before driving
herself to work around 3:00 a.m.
investigators said Reid raped and
strangled sites between 3:00 and 5:00
a.m. and left her body in a remote area
Reid was arrested after his DNA was
found on Stites from the beginning he
maintained his innocence he claimed he
in Stites were having an affair and had
consensual sex the day before her death
how many times did you two see each
other some does I would see it maybe
once or twice a week after the trial
forensic experts admitted to errors in
the time of death and the advocacy group
the Innocence Project says the murder
weapon was never tested for DNA three
forensic pathologists have come forward
and said that this is actually
impossible that Rodney committed the
crime all of it exonerates mr. Reid
and points to Jimmy Finnell Finnell was
initially a suspect in Stites murder but
his DNA was not found on Stites body his
attorney Bob Phillips says his client is
innocent Jimmy loved her he was gonna
marry her in three weeks Finnell later
served 10 years in prison for unrelated
kidnapping and improper sexual contact
in 2007 he pled guilty at his time he's
now out of prison now an inmate named
Arthur snow who was incarcerated with
Finnell and was a former member of the
Aryan Brotherhood is coming to Reid's
defense he claims Finnell confessed to
killing Stites because she was quote
sleeping with a black man behind his
back Pinellas attorney says snow story
is fiction Reid's brother Roderick told
CBS this morning this new evidence is
enough to save his brother's life
there's been testimony from people who
were in prison do you think that needs
to be brought in in this case now that
testimony from mr. snow needs to be
brought in all avenues need to be
traveled in order to get to the truth to
get justice for Stacey Stites and my
brother Rodney Reed we reached out to
Governor Abbott's office but have not
heard back as for Roger he plans to
travel to Washington DC next week
because the US Supreme Court is expected
to hear his brother's appeal but time is
running out because the execution date
is still November 20th Tony
Wow that's coming up quickly talk
ticking it very least why can't there be
a pause so you could just please
consider all this new evidence that's
some pretty compelling evidence come on
the story for sure
all right Omar thank you very much